- I am also witnessing many,
many of my friends leaving.
I just drove back from the
airport earlier this morning.
Saw about five or
six moving trucks.
I'm kinda counting them
now, because I had a friend
come over last night tell
me he's moving to Florida.
These are basically, upper
middle class and wealthy people.
They've attached
base to the city
and I've never wonder
about you know,
since maybe I stopped
being a liberal,
I always ask 'em, why do you
attack rich people so much?
Don't you realize you need them
to pay for the poor people?
(soothing instrumental music)
- This is the Rubin Report
and I'm David Rubin.
Friendly reminder everybody,
to subscribe to our YouTube
channel and click
that notification bell
so you're alerted when
new videos come out.
Joining me today is the
former mayor of New York City
and a special guest star of
one of the best ever episodes
of Seinfeld, Mayor
Rudy Giuliani.
Welcome to the Rubin Report.
- Thank you very much Dave.
- So I could basically spend
an hour talking to you about
Seinfeld and stuff you did
on Saturday Live.
- I know we could.
- I expect there are probably
some more pressing things
that you want to get to.
But I thought what
would be interesting,
instead of just going into
all of the stuff of today,
which we will get to, is that
especially for my younger
audience on YouTube,
that sort of know you
as New York City's mayor and
911, that version of you,
you had a whole life and a
political evolution before that
that in many ways is sort of
like my political evolution.
You fought off the mafia
as attorney general
and a whole bunch of stuff.
So can we just do sort
of Rudy Giuliani 101.
I mean, really from childhood
on and then we'll get
to the topics of the day.
- Sure, I'll do it real quick.
I was born in Brooklyn, second
generation Italian American.
I went to a Catholic
grammar school.
Then I moved from
Brooklyn to Long Island,
which was quite common in
those days and continued
in Catholic grammar school.
- What town in Long
Island were you in?
- Yeah, in Garden City and
North Bellmore Long Island,
two different places
in Long Island.
But I went to high
school in Brooklyn,
Bishop Loughlin High School,
which was a special
dioceses school.
In part because I wanted to
be a priest in my early days.
Kind of gave that
up when I found out
there were things
called girls. (laughs)
And kind of didn't work
with the priesthood.
Then I went to college in
the Bronx in Riverdale,
Manhattan College and
law school at NYU.
Graduated law school
and became a law clerk
to a really fine federal
judge, Lloyd McMahon,
who taught me how to
be a trial lawyer.
Then I entered the
U.S. Attorney's Office
at a very young age.
Because of his training, I sort
of started off as already a
pretty experienced trial lawyer
because he was a nice enough
man to kind of teach you
what you have to do
in the courtroom.
I loved being a trial lawyer.
I spent about five and
a half years doing that.
Tried a 100 cases or so.
Some mafia cases,
bank robbery cases,
white collar cases,
income tax evasion,
customs fraud, just about
everything you can think of
that are federal crimes.
Then I was the head of
the narcotics division,
which in those days
we focused a lot on
the French Connection, the
Italian French heroine trade,
the Columbian trade, all
the Columbian cartel people.
That was the first
time that somebody
put out a contract to kill me.
Vito Genovese's brother in law
threatened to have me killed
because I prosecuted him
and he got convicted.
The Columbian cartel
threatened to slit my throat.
But I was like 25, 26
years old and you don't,
I don't know, you feel
immortal at a young age.
Then I went off to
Washington to be the deputy,
chief of staff to the
deputy attorney general,
Harold Tyler in the
Ford administration.
That's where I started
to think about,
I had left the democratic party
as an assistant U.S. attorney
because I was investigating
a lot of corruption
in city government
under John Lindsey.
Even though John
Lindsey was a republican
who turned democrat, all the
people in city government
were democrats and all these
great society programs,
which I kinda
thought sounded nice,
it looked like none of it was
getting to the poor people.
It was all in the hands of the
administrator of the program,
his wife, some of the
crooked minority politicians
in the city,
who I quickly came to realize,
didn't really care about
their community, just
cared about getting rich
for themselves.
Very disillusioned.
I changed my registration
from democrat to independent.
Then I went off and I
worked for two years
in the Ford administration.
Met a lot of republicans
and found out
that they really
weren't terrible.
My impression from New
York were you know,
republicans only care
about rich people
and they're really very
mean and turned out,
they were just as caring
about poor people.
They just had a different
way of trying to move
them out of poverty.
Kinda made more sense to
me that you move people
out of poverty through
work than welfare.
I kinda had always a strong
aggressive foreign policy
with regard to Soviets,
so I always thought
of a Kennedy democrat.
In those days, there was a
fellow named Stu Jackson,
a senator, who was a very
hard-liner on foreign policy.
So then I switched to
being a republican.
I said well, let me try
the republican party.
Went into law practice, worked
for Ronald Reagan's election.
Ronald Reagan made me the
third ranking official
in the justice department.
I did that, I came
back to New York,
I became the U.S. attorney, I
prosecuted the five families
of the mafia, over
800 mafia people,
a large number of
Wall Street criminals,
Boesky probably being the
most famous one, Milken,
prosecuted three or four
sitting congressmen, and also
started using the
racketeering statute in a way
that it hadn't been used before,
to break up organized crime.
We took over the
Teamsters Union,
drove out organized crime.
We took over the casinos in
Las Vegas and got rid of them.
We took over the
Fulton Fish Market,
the whole industry of
the garment industry
and entertainment industry.
Strangely, the mafia controlled
the gay bars in New York.
A combination of our work and
then the advent of HIV/AIDS
got rid of those places, but
the mafia owned those bars
for purposes of extortion.
They owned every single one.
You couldn't open a gay bar
in New York and not have
Vito Genovese and
his number two guy
walk in on you and tell you
that he owned half the bar.
You'd say, "Why," and they'd say
"Because if we don't
we break your kneecap."
So we got them out of there.
I had a very--
Then I guess, the thing that
made me famous as the mayor
was a prosecuted a number
of the high level officials
in the Koch administration.
His chief political allies
and proved that they
were involved in a multi-million
dollar bribery scheme
to collect fines and divert
them to their own pocketbooks,
to the tune of about 15 or
20 million dollars a year.
- [Dave] Geez.
- That gave me a great
deal of name recognition
and I got the crazy idea
of running for mayor.
All my friends
told me I was nuts.
A republican couldn't win.
I thought maybe I was nuts,
but I was young enough
to try to be nuts and find
out if I would enjoy politics.
I was lucky enough
to get David Garth
as my political advisor.
I started off at
27 points behind.
I lost by two.
David taught me how to
be a political candidate.
It was the best showing a
republican had made in 40 years.
Since LaGuardia.
I got 48% of the vote.
I guess if I had gotten
20 I'd a given up,
but 48% of the vote,
I said to myself,
maybe I can have another
chance to do this.
- Then you eventually,
you decided to do it again
and the rest is history.
- Four years later,
four years later
I did it again and I won by a
very narrow margin, about 3%.
Then I ran for reelection
four years later
and I won by a landslide.
I was very fortunate.
I made a lot of promises.
I really went into the
job with the notion that
this is the first republican
in two generations.
I might be the last
republican mayor of New York.
Why not just do everything
I wanted to do and if I,
if it worked, I'd be a
hero and if it didn't,
they'd throw me out and
maybe 20 years later
they'd realize I was trying
to do the right thing.
I really had that attitude.
So I cut city government,
I cut city government
to what it should
be, by about 20%.
I laid off enormous
numbers of people.
I decreased everything in
city government interestingly,
but the police
department, because I had,
I had a couple years
right before I was mayor,
we had 2,200 murders.
We had about 1.1 million
people on welfare.
We had 10.5% unemployment.
We had a deficit that was
said to be about 700 million.
It really was 1.4 billion.
We had a situation
where 75% of the people
in the city wanted to leave.
So I ran on very much the
thing that Donald Trump
used four years ago,
which I might say
I kinda suggested he use, I
said you can't do any worse.
How can New York City
be any worse than
leading the country
in crime, murder,
violent crime, white collar
crime, organized crime, drugs?
We were ahead in everything.
How can we be any
worse than you know,
1.1 million people not working,
being supported by the other
people who are working?
No Fortune 500 company in 20
years had come to New York
and about 20 had moved out.
Our tax base was getting shrunk.
Even movies wouldn't be
made in New York anymore.
They were making the New
York movies in Toronto
because they were too
expensive to make in New York
and too dangerous.
So I said give me a chance.
I know everything's
wrong with it.
I have 12 years
experience of putting
all the bad guys in jail.
Maybe I can turn the knowledge
of everything that's wrong
with it into
straightening it out.
- All right, there's whole
bunch of off-shoots there.
- Very specific
plans to do that.
- Yeah all right, so there's
a couple different ways
we could go there.
So first off, I mentioned to
you when I was on your podcast
a couple days ago, we have
a sort of similar history.
Not only because of
the political evolution
of sort of democrat to
independent to what you know,
I would say I'm sort of
like a modern conservative
at this point, which I think
is sort of what you are.
Even we're sort of
in the same spot,
even on abortion, which is not
thought of as a conservative
position, specifically.
But the guy whose name you
actually didn't mention in there
was the guy that you
replaced as mayor,
which was David Dinkins, who
was a far left progressive.
He basically is the one that
sort of wrecked New York City
and I remember going
to New York City.
My grandparents lived there
and my great
grandparents lived there.
You couldn't go to Times Square.
You cleaned all of that stuff up
and I think a lot of
people right now are seeing
what de Blasio is doing
with many of the same ideas
as David Dinkins and
all these you know,
the big government progressives,
they're seeing that.
I do sense that maybe
there's another Rudy Giuliani
in the waiting.
But I gotta back up
to something else
because you're a second
generation Italian American
and you went after the mafia.
So you gotta explain
that a little bit more.
How did that, just in
terms of your own ethnicity
and identity, how is that?
- Well, you know I,
I knew the mafia from
growing up in Brooklyn
and from being an
Italian family.
I was not one of those people
where you had to tell me
you know, what is the mafia.
I knew what it was.
I knew its history
from the Black Hand,
when the Italian American
immigrants first came
to this country at the
turn of the century.
The Black Hand
would prey on them.
I remember stories in my
family that my grandfather,
who ran a large, large
tavern in Coney Island,
several times he was
required to pay
money to the mafia.
Once when he didn't, they
burned part of his store.
I was told what bullies they
are, how terrible they are.
I had an impression of them
as being very bad for
the Italian people.
Then obviously found
out, as I got older,
that there was also a
tremendous prejudice
that every Italian
was part of the mafia.
Including at times,
I would be told that I
was part of the mafia.
So it created both
sets of problems.
When I became an assist
to United States attorney
it wasn't really to
pursue the mafia,
it was to be a trial lawyer.
That's what I always
wanted to be all my life
and try all different
kinds of crimes,
but it just so happened that
that was the era in which
the FBI was just beginning
to really go after the mafia.
J Edgar Hoover had always
preferred to go after communists
than the mafia.
I tried one big mafia
case as a young lawyer
against a fellow
named Vito Gazia.
His name was actually,
his nickname was Peter.
They all have nicknames.
He was the son in
law of Vito Genovese.
We were allowed to prosecute
him because he cheated
on Vito's sister.
So Vito basically
let the witnesses,
gave witnesses the permission
to testify against him.
I had no idea why I
had all these witnesses
testifying against
this big mafia guy.
In the middle of the trial
he threatened to kill me,
which because he was
a little bit nuts.
So for the first time I
hadda have protection.
I convicted him and it
was a big conviction.
But I think I had that
conviction, thanks to Vito,
who was willing to
tell three or four
of his loan shark victims,
it's okay to testify
against my brother in law
because he's screwing around
on my sister. (laughs)
Then I left, I
went to Washington.
I was one of the people that
help establish the FISA report.
So when we litigate all this
stuff about the FISA court,
Joe de Geneva, who you
see on television and I,
were the two lawyers who
helped develop the FISA court.
I dealt with the
church committee.
I learned Washington,
came back to New York,
I was in the law practice.
Then I became the
third ranking official
in the justice department
under Ronald Reagan,
and that's where I really
became interested in politics.
Because Reagan was to
me, bigger than life.
Just a great, great man,
just a natural president,
natural leader
and unbelievably underestimated,
much like our present
president and a lot
of his success came
from being underestimated.
- Yeah, so we'll get to
our current president
in a little bit.
Obviously, you've
talked about you know,
what 911 was like,
many, many times.
So maybe sort of briefly,
you know I told you
this the other day, I
lived in New York City
on the Upper East
Side during 911.
My dad worked in the garment
center, he saw the second plane
hit, I had my grandma lived
there, plenty of family there.
We were all there and
truly one of the things
that I remember most you know,
beyond the tangible stuff,
the smell that you could smell
for weeks and all of that,
is that you calmed
everybody down
and showed actual true
leadership in a time
when we needed it in
an unimaginable way.
Do you, in many ways, feel
like everything that you just
laid out in these few minutes
sort of led you to that moment?
I mean, when you got the call,
I mean were you just ready
to be a leader in that moment?
- Yes, strange to say, but yes.
To make it even more direct,
I had just finished
the first draft
of a book called leadership.
Somehow about a year before,
I'd been wanting to write
a book forever and ever.
I started three different books.
I could never figure
out exactly what
I wanted to write about.
Somehow about a year before
I got the idea that I'd write
about leadership because
I had been in a lot
of different
leadership positions,
both in government
and in business.
I ran a coal mine once,
which is all together
a different story.
Got it out of bankruptcy.
So I thought I would write
about how I was able to do that.
At least, the
lessons that I used
to teach myself a new business.
I have a sort of
general feeling that
I'd rather have a great
manager than a subject matter
expert in any situation.
Because management
skills are sometimes
harder to find than
subject matter expertise.
The book talks about 20
lessons or so on leadership.
So by the time
September 11 happened,
it was in a final draft form.
It was sitting in my desk.
I was gonna publish it when
I left the mayor's office.
Probably the day
before September 11,
I was pretty arrogant.
If you had asked me, you know,
could you handle an emergency?
I'd say of course.
I mean, I been the
mayor of New York.
It's a crisis of week,
it's an emergency of month
and it's a catastrophic
emergency every six months.
I mean, we had hurricanes,
we had airplane crashes,
we had subway derailments,
we had hostage situations,
we had terrorist attacks.
I mean everyday
it was something.
I had developed the
first mayor's office
of emergency management
because we had had a terrorist
attack the year before
I came into office, in 1993.
Probably another reason
that elected me is we were
very poorly prepared for that.
I established a
special mayor's office
of emergency management.
All they did was train us
on how to get ready for
nuclear attack, sarin gas,
which was a big
problem back then,
anthrax, which we actually did
get attacked with during 911.
We went through West Nile virus.
People don't remember that,
but it was kind of a mini-form
of the pandemic that
we just went through.
So we were very skilled.
When I say we, I
had a great team.
We were very skilled in
emergency management.
All of a sudden 911 happens,
I arrive there, I
look at the scene.
I see a man throw himself
out of the 100th floor.
I turned to my police
commissioner, Bernie Carey,
and I say, "Bernie, we're
not prepared for this."
Whatever we did, this
challenges everything we know
and we're gonna have to
use our instincts here.
We don't have, we've got
24 plans for emergencies.
We don't have one
that says airplanes
crashing into
buildings like torpedo.
We had to make it up
as we moved along.
But the fact that we
had that experience,
kind of made it possible
for us to do that I think,
a little better than
might have been done
if we hadn't that experience.
- I know this is probably a
little bit of an odd question,
but did you realize at
the time how important
just sort of remaining, just
the optics of being in charge
and being calm in it were?
Because that, it felt like, I
mean, I remember being there,
it felt like the world was over
or nothing even
remotely close to normal
was ever gonna come back.
Every time I turned
on CNN you were there
and you were in the streets
or wherever you were
and it was like oh,
somebody's trying to make
some sense of this thing,
somebody's in charge.
- Yeah, I knew that
on a smaller scale.
I didn't realize the
enormity of it right away.
I thought of it, since I
had done so many emergencies
in the city, it began for me as
gigantic big, way beyond
anything we did before,
but involving my city.
But I mean, part of
handling an emergency
is you control your emotions
and no matter how confused
you are, no matter
how afraid you are,
and no matter how upset you
are about somebody dying,
you just control.
You do...
I call it a Scarlett O'Hara.
I'll think about it tomorrow.
You know, I remember
when I was first told
that Father Judge died.
He was the first person
whose body we found.
Father Judge was my close
friend for eight years.
He was the person that taught
me how to deal with death
first time I lost
three fire fighters.
He was an extraordinary
Franciscan priest.
I found out that he died
almost simultaneously
with my wanting to call my
priest fire commissioner
and say go get Father
Judge, I need him.
Meaning, I needed him for
advice on how to explain
to people, at that point we
thought 12,000 people were dead.
As I'm thinking that, my
fire commissioner walked in,
Tom Von Essen, and he says,
"Mayor, we got a real problem.
"They're carrying Father
Judge's body out of the rubble.
"They're taking him over
to St. Peter's church."
I said, "Is he dead?"
He said, "Yes."
I would say, if
it hadn't been a,
if I hadn't been in the
middle of it having to run it,
I probably would
have gone in a room
and cried for about 10 minutes,
because he was so important.
But I had to say to
myself, okay, contain it,
stop it, you'll figure
this out tonight.
You'll figure out
what he taught you
and you'll use it tonight.
So I had been trained like
that from earlier emergencies,
that you just don't show it.
You just,
you put aside the emotion
and you think about
what's the next practical
thing that you have to do
in order to keep this
thing under control.
- Yeah, and you did.
We could obviously spend the
whole hour talking about this.
I just have one
other thing on this
and then we'll move on
to some other things.
You know, because right
now we live in such a time
where it seems like
everyone's so polarized
and so hating and all of that.
You know, New York City has the
idea that we all
hate each other.
You know, I never
found New York City
to be like that actually.
We're kind of rough
on the outside,
but if you ask anyone
for directions,
they're happy to
talk to you usually.
But I do remember for
a few months after 911
there was like a really
special feeling on the street.
I remember actually, I told
you I lived on the Upper East
and I went to play
basketball at the courts
right by Gracie Mansion
on 90th and York.
- Yeah I know them well.
- Maybe two or three weeks
after 911 and we were playing
basketball you could still
smell the soot in the air
and all that and two
guys got into a fight
and they were about
to punch each other.
Like, it was about to happen
and they both started crying.
Basically, everyone on
the court started crying
at the same, it all kind of
teared up at the same time.
That there was something
so special about that
and I wonder,
well can you just talk
about that feeling after
and also do you think
there's a chance we can ever
get back to something like that,
for as crazy as
things seem right now?
- I hope that's
still there, Dave.
I hope so.
It was an extraordinary,
I'd say three, four weeks.
It was like the
world had changed.
We were all friends,
by all friends I mean,
Hillary Clinton
and Chuck Schumer
and George Bush and
the democratic congressman and
the republican congressmen.
They came as a group.
I took them on a
tour as a group.
These are people that
nowadays are all trying
to put each other in jail.
All they were interested in
was, legitimately interested in,
is how can we help, how
can we get out of this,
how can we learn from it?
Very constructive.
I mean, I got more offers
of help than I needed.
Then I got two very, I got
two really terrific calls.
One from the governor
of Florida, Jeb Bush
and the other from the mayor
of Chicago, Mayor Daley,
and they both wanted to know
if they could send observers
to watch so that they can
develop an emergency management
office like we had for
when it happens to them.
They didn't say if
it happens to them,
instead, but when
it happens to them.
I thought that was a very, very
intelligent decision to make
looking into the future.
Then a few others did that.
I think, I've tried to think
of what's the difference
between that and then
the pandemic, where
there's a certain
amount of unity
that came out of it,
but not for very long and
it quickly developed into
almost a political thing.
Into a political
thing, not almost.
First of all, I think
the difference is that
an attack on your country
by a specific group
of foreigners or enemy, is
a very, very jarring thing
that does bring you together.
It's like somebody, you're
feuding with your family members
and you're all at home fighting
and then all of a sudden people
want to attack your house
and take the entire house
from the entire family.
I think you get over the feuding
when you're fighting
for the same cause.
I think a thing like the
pandemic is more diffused.
There was so many different
explanations for it.
There was so much
confusion about it
and contradiction about it.
Then right away the attempt
to make political gain on it.
It didn't take a week or so,
of course I see if
from republican eyes,
but for Schumer and Pelosi to
say that Trump wasn't handling
it right and he didn't
pick it up right away.
Of course, ignoring the fact
that they didn't either.
He picked it up before they did.
She was inviting
people to go out
and the idiot mayor here in
the city for two weeks after
Trump declared it
was an emergency,
was telling people to go out.
So there was plenty of
political blame to go around.
September 11, there probably
was that political blame also
but everybody stopped it and
said you know, it's stupid.
All that political
blame was stupid.
Pelosi didn't cause the
pandemic and neither did Trump
and neither did
Schumer or Cuomo.
China did.
China caused it and then
we all reacted to something
that was extraordinary,
something new,
something we didn't know about.
How could they have
reacted to it properly?
They didn't know
what this virus was.
How was Fauci, everyone
says well Fauci had about
three different views on it.
Well, he did.
But he didn't know what it was.
He may be a genius
but he's not God.
Same thing with September 11.
People would criticize
the reaction to it
and I'd say, geez, everybody's
doing the best they can.
This is something we
never faced before.
So you know, I think we're
doing a pretty good job
for something we
didn't face before.
That existed with September 11.
It doesn't exist now.
We go after the pettiest
little thing right away.
- Yeah, it's a pretty scary
premise that what we need
potentially to bring us
together is the unspeakable.
But you know, a few
years after you left
and you were no longer mayor,
I don't think a lot of people
remember that you actually
were gonna run for senator
or you started running
for senator from New York
against Hillary Clinton
and then you were--
- I was gonna run.
- Yeah, you were diagnosed
with prostate cancer
and then Rick Lasio, who I think
was just a local politician
in Long Island, if
I'm not mistaken,
he stepped in and
Hillary obviously won.
- Rick was the
member of congress,
he was a member of congress.
- Member of congress.
But obviously, he
didn't make major waves,
where I think with
you and Hillary,
it would have been
a real battle.
- Oh, it'd a been a
great race. (laughs)
- Yeah, do you ever
think about that,
that regardless of whether
you would have won or lost,
that history could
have absolutely changed
because of that election.
- It could have, I mean it
could have changed, sure.
I mean, yes.
Sure you think about it and
but I'm not, I don't
dwell a lot on the things
that didn't happen.
I sort of dwell on the
things that did happen
and did they happen
right or wrong
and if they happened
wrong, how do we adjust.
So it happened, it was something
that I wasn't meant to do
and then I did run for president
to try to run against her again.
I lost and she lost.
So we never did get to
run against each other.
- Do you regret,
I guess I don't even
have to ask this question
'cause you don't dwell
on things, but you know,
you sort of had this strategy
that you were gonna wait
sort of, for the big
stuff till Florida
and then it just didn't happen.
But I guess I don't have
to ask you if you regret it
because you don't dwell.
- No, I don't regret it.
I think, I actually think
when I look back on it,
two things make it easy.
One, I think the strategy
would not have worked
no matter how we did it.
I was too moderate a republican
for them to nominate.
I'm the last nominee to try
to become the republican
candidate for president
who's at all pro-choice.
I'm you know, three
months pro-choice.
I'm one of those people who
is pro-life individually,
but I am willing to
say that other people
have different moral
views about this
and a woman should have
a three month period
in which to decide
whether or not
she can have the baby.
I don't like that, I
wish it were different.
I offer, when I was
mayor, I would offer
and the other side
would get very angry,
offer adoption as
an alternative.
But then ultimately, I think
it's the woman's choice
and finally, I can't find
it in my heart to put people
in jail for it, which is the
only way you can enforce it.
Now, the whole abortion
debate has become now,
like crazy, like
everything else has.
Course, now we're talking about
abortion in the eighth month
and we have this crazy governor
in Virginia who is
talking about abortion
after the baby's born.
I don't know if
he's just stupid.
Yeah, I don't know if he's
stupid and he didn't know
what he said is too
stubborn to go back on it.
What he really means is that
you should get a waiting period
so that the doctor and
the mother can talk over
what to do with the baby.
There's nothing you
can do with the baby
except commit murder, right.
- Yeah, well it's interesting
and I'm glad you mentioned that.
I know you read my book,
I take the 12 week also.
So the three month position
and people will say to me,
well Dave, you seem to
align with the conservatives
on so many issues.
This is the one that you don't
really align with them on.
I'm actually fine with that
because I always find
that the conservatives
that disagree with us on
this, they're always willing
to talk about it respectfully.
Do you ever find that they
won't talk about it respectfully
versus on the other side,
where if you don't
agree, you're done?
- Yeah, I mean,
I'm not sure it was
always that way,
but the way it is broken down
now and I hope this isn't
my own prejudice, I
find far more ability
within the conservative
movement, republican movement,
to talk about our
disagreements without anger
than on the democratic side.
For example, when I was running,
Mike Huckabee and I were running
against each other
and after one debate,
I think it was the 3rd or 4th
debate and we're good friends,
he said to me, "You know mayor,
I'm a minister and I have
"trouble, even with your
narrow pro-choice position.
"It would be hard for
me if I dropped out
"to endorse you in the primary."
Although I have to think,
he gave me some reasons why
he thought maybe I was the
best candidate other than him.
I said, "Well Mike, I'm very
impressed with you too."
He said, "And the reason
I would endorse you is
"because you're
honest about it."
He contrasted me with Romney,
who he said had changed
his position on everything.
Romney had been pro-choice,
he became completely pro-life.
Romney had been for gun control,
he became a lifetime
member of the NRA.
Romney was for gay rights.
Romney was then totally
against even basic gay rights.
Not even gay marriage
or just you know.
He didn't want gay
rights to be included
in any of the civil
rights laws that we had.
He had signed a similar
bill, like I did,
that allowed for
partnership laws.
Before marriage, one of the
things that was done was
you could protect
yourself legally,
by becoming a civil partner.
I think I was the
second official in
America to sign that.
Interestingly, that
never caused me problems
in the republican party.
I used to get endorsed
every time I ran
by the gay republican group,
called the Log Cabin Club.
It was never as hot button
as issue as abortion.
I think when you see
how it played out,
it played out without as much
political division.
- Yeah, so let's move
forward to sort of,
what's going on today because
there's a lot of stuff
happening in our cities.
I know you're no fan
of your current mayor,
even though you still
live in New York City.
But de Blasio seemingly
has done a series of things
that are the exact things that
you were trying to clean up
when you became mayor.
Can you talk a little
bit about what it's like
to live in a city that you love,
that you were the mayor of,
to watch it go backwards
and as you know,
I mentioned this to
you the other day,
but I've at times in my
family's history we had dozens.
I think at one time something
around 50 family members
at one time that lived
in New York City.
We now have one person left,
my sister and her husband
and two kids just left
over the last two months.
I now have one second
cousin left, that's it.
After having a rich
history in New York City,
it kills me to say that.
But can you talk about what's
going on in New York City
right now and maybe
what you would do
to turn around
some of this stuff?
- Well, first of all, it's
the saddest I've ever been
about New York City.
I'm much more down about
it than I was, let's say,
when I ran or even when
I was U.S. Attorney.
I mean, when I was U.S.
Attorney, I wasn't sure I wanted
to run for mayor, but I
was seeing all the things
that were wrong
with New York City.
That's when the 2,000 murders
a year were taking place
and the mafia had control of,
almost every business
in this city.
You couldn't build a building.
You couldn't have your garbage
taking out without paying.
But I always felt there
was solutions to this.
There were things
that we could do.
I always felt there was the
will there to change it.
Now I'm not, maybe it's
because I'm not as involved
in politics and I don't go
to the local groups as much,
I don't feel that same
desire to change it.
There's almost a hopelessness
and I am also witnessing
many, many of my
friends leaving.
I just drove back from the
airport earlier this morning.
There were about five
or six moving trucks.
I'm kinda counting them now
because I had a friend come over
last night tell me
he's moving to Florida.
These are basically, upper
middle class and wealthy people.
They're the tax
base of the city.
I've never wondered about you
know, since maybe I stopped
being a liberal,
I always ask 'em, why do you
attack rich people so much?
Don't you realize you need them
to pay for the poor people?
When I was the
mayor of this city,
the budget of New York
City is larger than all,
but about 10 states.
I needed tremendous amount
of money to take care
of Medicare, Medicaid,
welfare, aid for children,
aid for battered children,
all the things we do,
the public hospitals system.
New York City provides
universal healthcare
through its public
hospital system.
Only place in America,
I think that does that,
and we've been doing
it for 120 years.
So our bills are very high.
So, who pays those bills?
Wall Street, all those
beautiful apartments you see
on Park Avenue and 5th Avenue
and on the West Side now.
Every time a new area gentrified
and the tax base
started to go up,
I would see it as I
can do more for people.
I can do more to make this
city a little more balanced,
in terms of rich and poor
and a little more opportunity
for people to move
out of poverty, 'cause for
me, there's no question
that capitalism is the
only way out of poverty.
The rest of it is a false
program that's presented
to people by condemn.
- So what would you
do, like little things,
like that now you can jump
a turnstile at the subway
and you know, they won't fine
you, they won't stop you.
Now we see, I mean there's
videos everyday on Twitter.
You see 20 people do it at once.
Kids just open up the door, you
know the handicap accessible
door and just let
tons of people in.
That, in many ways,
de Blasio's plans,
which sort of sound right,
oh we want to help people
that are poor, that's
always how it's sold,
actually encourage lawlessness.
Then, really let's talk
about just the rioting
that's happening
all over the city.
I've got a friend who
lives on Spring Street,
who has abandoned New York City.
He's got a great apartment,
he hasn't been there in months
and his friend took a
video from his apartment
and all hell was breaking loose.
I mean, it truly looked
like a 3rd world country.
- Similar experience.
- New York City.
- You know, when I was a
prosecutor for many, many years,
16, 17, 18 years,
I was a federal prosecutor,
which meant I always tried
very big cases.
My cases, you don't
try the small cases.
As a local prosecutor,
you'll try the murder case
and the theft case.
Federal prosecutor, you're
trying organized crime,
you're trying very, very
intricate financial fraud.
High enough levels so it
arises to federal crime.
I was not a natural proponent
of the broken windows theory.
It didn't even make sense to me
when it was first told to me.
Because I always thought
we paid too much attention
to the small things, not enough
attention to the big crime.
It was taught to me by
about 1981, when I was the
associate attorney general
of the United States.
We established a commission
on violent crime.
Professor James Q. Wilson
was the vice chair of it.
I got very close to Professor
Wilson, who developed
this theory at Harvard
with Professor Kelling.
What he tried to
explain to me was,
first of all, you're not
an expert on street crime.
I'm gonna make you one.
You're an expert on
high level crime,
even mafia crime is
high level crime.
Let's take a look
at street crime,
that's what you
did for two years.
He said an awful lot
of it has to do with
what the young people
see in the community.
He said, let's make
it really simple.
If they see a lawful community,
where the expectation is
that you don't ruin other
people's property by putting
graffiti all over it, that
you have to pay when you go
through the turnstile, if you
take something from someone
you have to give it back or
there are punishments for that.
He said if society
is based on that,
you have very little big crime.
Reverse it.
If the society looks
like your New York,
where everything is
filled with graffiti,
as if somebody's property
doesn't mean anything,
where you don't have to
pay for the turnstile,
where you can spit
on the sidewalk,
where you can urinate
in the street,
where you can do
anything you want,
the attitude begins
at a very early age
that there are no limits,
there are restriction.
By the time they start
to get to the big crime,
it's really too
hard to deal with.
I even translated
that into my theory
of how you stop a riot, which
they failed to do this time
and we never failed to do it.
You stop a riot
before it is a riot.
You anticipate.
You see a protest,
wonderful things protests.
People have a right to call
me names, call you names,
whatever they want to do.
But I used to give
them a lecture,
'cause Dinkins had
so many protests,
I just had to stop it cold.
I wasn't gonna have any.
So I gave a speech and I said,
"Let's understand each other.
"You can have all the
protests you want.
"I'm pro-first amendment.
"You can do anything
you want protesting,
"however, the minute
you throw a rock
"you're gonna go to jail.
"You're not gonna get arrested,
"you're gonna go
to Riker's Island.
"I'll let you sit there for
a day before I even take you
"before a judge.
"If you scratch a car,
you're gonna get arrested.
"If you burn anything, I'm
gonna try to put you in jail
"for a long time.
"And if you physically
harm someone,
"we're talking five,
six, seven, eight years.
"And if you're a juvenile, I
won't treat you as a juvenile.
"Treat you as an adult."
So, I'm gonna be really,
really nice to you if you have
a peaceful protest.
I'm gonna protect you.
I'm gonna make it
easy for you to do it
and I don't really
care what you say.
You can call me a Nazi, you
can call me whatever you want.
But it isn't be the
last act of criminality.
It's the first one
we're gonna go after
because David Dinkins had
a theory he called venting
and it caused the Crown Heights
and the Washington
Heights riots.
They let it go on
for three days.
By the time Ray Kelly had to
solve it in Crown Heights,
many, many Jewish people,
one had been killed,
many had been beaten
with kind of a pogrom.
They did the same thing
in Washington Heights.
That's essentially
what happened to us
in all those democratic cities.
In Minnesota, they didn't
enforce the law for three
or four days.
In New York, I mean I
have pictures of people
going into stores, walking
out with television,
walking out with liquor,
the cops are watching.
Cops are not observers of crime.
They're not there
to record the crime.
They're there to stop it.
- Can you talk a
little bit about
the tension between the cops?
- The more difficulty.
They had exactly--
I maintain that these riots,
in part were caused by
the boy mayor of Minneapolis,
who let them take over
the police precinct.
Once he let them take
over a police precinct,
that affects everybody
all of the the country.
All these ANTIFA groups,
Black Lives Matter groups,
man let's see if we can push
our police department like that.
What they found were, and I
say this not to be partisan,
just to be accurate, they
found that to be true
in democratic cities.
The democratic mayors were
afraid to confront them
because they're afraid of
the base going against.
They made a political
calculation about
the enforcement
of the law, rather than
protecting their citizens.
That's disgraceful.
- Yeah, can you talk a
little bit about the tension
that exists right now between
the New York police department
and de Blasio?
'Cause I've got a couple
contacts there who I mean,
they're read to revolt
against the guy.
Like, it is an extraordinary
mess right now.
- They believe that
his incompetence
puts their lives at risk.
They believe that his big
mouth, his condemning of them,
this goes back to
the very beginning
with two police officers
called Ramos and Lou,
when there were
riots in Baltimore.
De Blasio, shooting
his big mouth off,
said something about
our police department
also having problems in racism.
He didn't reflect on the fact
that his police department
is not a majority white
police department anymore.
That combination of
Dinkins, Koch and me,
we gave Bloomberg
a non-majority anything
police department
and Bloomberg made
it even better.
We're pretty proud of that.
But instead of making that
point, which might have helped
keep the problem away from
us, he wants to put us in
with you know, if there are
racist police departments,
racist police departments.
Within a few days of that,
a crazy man from Baltimore
comes up to New York, two
police officers, Ramos and Lou,
are sitting there, guarding
a housing development.
Protecting black people
and the guy puts a bullet
in the back of both
of their heads.
So the police department
surmise, whether fair or not,
why would he have
thought of New York
if big mouth hadn't
made this statement?
That's the time they
turned their back on him,
told him they didn't want
him coming to the funeral,
didn't want him coming to the.
Then it's been a series
of unfortunate statements
that he'll say he had to
teach his son how to deal
with the danger presented to him
by the New York City
police department.
He didn't mention the fact
that he really shoulda taught
his son how to deal with
the danger presented to him
by other black young men.
I mean, the police department,
his chance of being
touched by the police
department in comparison
to being killed by a
black man in New York
is less than 1%, as opposed
to 75% of the murder victims
in New York City are black
and 75% of the
murderers are black.
So I mean, you gotta be a
stupid father just to train
your son to worry about
the police when my factor
of about 50 to one is much
more likely to be killed
by another young black man.
- Do you think the average New
Yorker is waking up to this
and seeing the
chaos on the streets
and everything
you're talking about?
- Oh yes.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
- Do you think a republican
or a conservative
could ever win in
New York again?
- We're at the point where
republican, independent
or reformed democrat,
you know somebody that's
completely removed
from the political machine.
It's so helpful that I could
not have done what I did
in New York had I
been a democrat.
I owe no one a darn
thing, nothing.
I could get rid of 20,000
people in city government
and the unions could go crazy.
None of them supported me.
I didn't expect them to
support me in the future.
I think I woulda done it
anyway, but I'm not sure.
It takes a lot of
courage to do that.
But I had to make so
few compromises, if any,
to become mayor, that I
mean, I guess I didn't think
I'd even be mayor.
So I was like free as a
bird to do what I wanted.
The few people that did help
me, they really were helping me
because they were so
fed up with the city,
the one thing they
wanted from me--
I knew if I reduced crime I was
gonna be a successful mayor.
I knew I was a one issue mayor.
I also knew if I didn't reduce
crime they'd throw me out.
Now, we turned out to do
a lot of other things.
We reduced welfare
by 600,000 people.
We got rid of homelessness.
We set up a whole new
thing for administration
for children services and
dealt with domestic violence,
much, much better
than ever before.
And we reduced taxes by 35%,
which had never been
done in New York City.
My first tax
reduction was only 3%.
My deputy mayor came
to me and he said,
"Mayor you set a record
for tax reduction."
I said, "Peter,
that's impossible."
Only 3%.
He was my best friend,
he also laughed at me,
he said it's the only
tax reduction ever.
Even LaGuardia was
a liberal. (laughs)
- That tells you everything.
- We did a lot of remarkable
things but the crime reduction
was the thing that made
everything possible.
Once they saw we could
do the impossible,
they had confidence in us to
do the normal political things
that could be done.
- If you were mayor
of Seattle right now
and there was an
autonomous zone,
or whatever they're
calling it now.
It gets renamed
every day, right.
But there was a zone in your
city that was in effect,
a lawless zone that
police can not go to
in any effective way,
that people could do
whatever they want,
they've taken over stores
and public parks
and everything else,
what would you do today?
Because the mayor, in effect,
she's basically saying,
it's lawful, it's fine and
Trump stay out of the way.
In many ways, I think
she's trying to set up,
I think between her and Insley,
the governor of Washington,
they're trying to set up a trap.
They're showing hey, we
progressives let anyone
do whatever they want so the
whole place is gonna crumble
and Trump's gonna
have to send in troops
or the National Guard or
something and then they'll say,
see, he's the exact
authoritarian we
always said he was.
What would you do if
you were the mayor?
- First of all, it's
inconceivable to me
that we'd be at that point.
Because the first time
they put up a barricade
and my police couldn't go
in would be the last time
they did it.
They'd all be
sitting in jail now.
They wouldn't be around.
If I had to come in now,
if they put me in charge
of that city right now
with the barricades there,
I would make an assessment
of what I needed
to get rid of them and
I would get rid of them
at the earliest possible moment.
I would tell them, I think
if I were you I would leave
because it's gonna
be much more pleasant
if you leave than if I
have to make you leave.
But don't mess around with
me because I'm not joking.
I'm not one of these silly
wussy liberal mayors.
Like, make my day.
Give me a chance to
get you outta there
and I'll get you outta there.
You're not paying taxes,
you're not helping my city,
you're smoking dope like crazy.
Maybe I'd send DEA in first
and wipe out the drug dealers.
Then I'd get about half of
them out and it'd be easier.
In fact,
I think maybe if I were
the U.S. Attorney there,
I would send the Drug
Enforcement Administration in
and do a major raid and
get all the cocaine,
meth, marijuana--
I know it's legal in
Washington, but it's not legal
in the United States of America.
Sometimes I think when you
deal with organized crime
you gotta take advantage of
laws like the tax evasion laws
in order to
accomplish something.
But if you want to make the
problem easier for the uniformed
police officer, go take a
look at all the federal crimes
they're committing and go
in with a federal task force
and arrest them.
Drug Enforcement
Administration's a tough outfit.
I don't think they've
encountered something like
and if they been policed
by the Seattle police,
they haven't encountered Drug
Enforcement Administration.
It's a different animal.
- I want to shift.
I want to shift to Trump a
little bit because obviously,
you guys are friends,
you have a history.
So I want to know a little
bit about just the history
of when he was just a
real estate developer,
before he was even
a reality TV host,
but what that was like when you
were mayor and you knew him.
But also, I mentioned
this to you last week,
that when I was at Mar-A-Lago,
right before Christmas,
you guys were sitting at
the table right next to us.
Unfortunately, I didn't
get to say hi to you,
but this was right when
impeachment was blowing up.
Everybody in the news was
saying the walls are closing in,
Trump's freaking out,
this whole thing,
but I'm watching the two of
you outta the corner of my eye,
Trump has no tie on, you
guys are laughing up a storm,
having a ball and everybody's
saying the guy's freaking out.
Then I had a very nice
exchnage with him.
But can you just talk a
little bit about Trump.
- Well first of all,
he never freaked out
during the whole experience.
There's even an article
in the Washington Post,
you want to talk
about fake news.
There's an article that
one day Jay Sekulow,
who's my co-council
and were there,
with several other lawyers.
The President had lost it and
he started throwing papers
around and he threw
something at Jane Raskin,
who was one of our lawyers.
We get back to our office
and the Washington Post
has this story.
First of all, he didn't
throw anything around.
Number two, Jane wasn't
even at the meeting.
There were no women
at the meeting.
But the reporter wanted it,
like he assaulted a woman.
I said, why don't you
make it he threw it at me.
At least I was there.
He didn't throw it at me, but
you can say he threw it at me.
- Yeah, but they don't like you.
- They want him to
throw it at a woman
so they made up a woman!
I mean, you can't believe
how cynical I became.
I began representing him
thinking that Mueller
was a fair guy.
I knew him for years.
I mean, he worked under me
in the Justice Department
and I worked with him in 911.
He was kind of a rookie.
He had just become
director of the FBI.
I always thought of
him as a fair man.
I got very worried, from the
outside, when he started hiring
all these political
operatives, 'cause having been
a prosecutor, you don't do that.
You don't do that for
the credibility of
your investigation.
I mean, if they hired me
to investigate Hillary
I wouldn't go out and
hire her worst enemy.
Or if somebody else was
to investigate Hillary,
they wouldn't hire
me to go investigate
'cause I've made some pretty
harsh statements about her.
So you try to find, in
the prosecution field,
you can find a lot of
apolitical people, good ones.
So it said to me either
Mueller is losing something
or because the media let's
them get away with things
they don't let us get away with,
they're becoming very sloppy.
Because had a republican put
together that kind of a group
to investigate Hillary
Clinton or Joe Biden,
there'd a been holy hell to pay.
People who contributed
to the campaign,
people who have made
statements that he was insane,
people that made statements
that he had to be stopped
under all circumstances.
They shouldn't be on
a prosecution for.
So I thought gee, Bob has
kinda lost it a little.
Then when I came into the case
and I had my first meeting
with him and he didn't
even know whether he
could indict the President or
not, he had to go look it up,
I said this guy's
really become lazy.
Didn't realize that
he had an illness.
I didn't realize that
the guy is suffering from
some kind of a cognitive
brain impairment
where he can't seem
to remember things
or be on top of things.
After that three hour meeting,
that was the last
time we saw him.
They kept him
under lock and key,
kinda like what they're
doing with Biden.
- That's exactly what
I was just gonna say.
What about Trump
before all of this?
'Cause obviously you guys
have become allies now
and you spoke at the
convention of course
and all that stuff, but
just from the pre-Trump,
when he used to be
a media darling,
when he was just a New
York City businessman,
whether you liked him or
not, that's what he was.
Are you shocked at sort
of just the way everything
is framed these days?
- No, I'm not shocked,
you know, I'd have to
go through a long story
to tell you the whole evolution.
I expected, unlike the
popular conception,
that he would be
a good president.
I also thought he would
probably get a lot of credit,
more than he gets, because
he would defy expectations,
kind of like Reagan did.
You know, they all thought
Reagan was a big dope.
Reagan was one of the
presidents who probably was
the best writer.
I always tell people to go
read his love letters to Nancy
and you find out what
a good writer he was.
I used to help write speeches
for him and I was shocked
at what a good writer he was
because I had the prejudice
from the northeast that
he was just an actor.
Well, I knew that Trump had
a very, very facile mind,
very, very complex mind,
had a very great interest in
politics and public affairs.
You know, his interest in
trade goes back 30 years.
His idea of our intervening
too much goes back 20 years.
So these are things you
would talk to him about
and because I was in politics,
the two things that I talked
to him about most were golf,
golf, baseball and politics.
We became friends
really because,
when I ran in 1989, I was
gonna run against Ed Koch.
He thought Ed Koch was
had become a very bad mayor.
He supported me in every one
of my political campaigns.
We became good friends,
I joined his golf course.
My son turns out to
be a fabulous golfer,
professional for a while.
He and the President
golf together a lot.
They became very close
and Donald became
like an uncle to Andrew.
So it's through how
nice he's been to my son
that I can see the
personal side of him
and I also saw him
bring up his children
and he's a remarkably
good father.
So I see a side of him
that people don't see.
He was also always there
when we had police officers
in trouble, fire
fighters in trouble.
he and George Steinburner,
there's a whole group
of New Yorkers that
somehow were painted as,
maybe because they
were more conservative
or they were more republican,
they were painted as some
kind of ogres and they really
were very, very kind
and very philanthropic.
You can count on it.
Finally, the thing
I liked about Trump
is he wasn't a complainer.
The mayor has to award
a lot of projects.
I was scrupulous about it.
Everybody supported me
in the real estate area.
Anybody I gave it to,
it could have been
considered a political favor.
So I would set up committees
to make the decision.
I would only reverse
them if they made
a really stupid
decision, and invariably,
my friends would be cut out
and they come to
me and complain.
Then I would say to them,
didn't you support me
because you wanted low crime?
Yes.
I said hasn't your
property value gone up 30%
because the crime went down?
Yes.
Isn't that good enough?
They would say no.
We wanted that project.
He never did that.
I turned him down for the
biggest project that I had,
which was the Time Warner
building because we thought
somebody else's
design was better.
He never once
complained about it.
So this idea that he's always
looking for advantages,
it's not true.
He negotiates in a
way that looks like
he's gonna squeeze out every,
but then he's very, very careful
to stay within the rules.
He always had very good
attorneys, the best.
Very good accountants.
I don't have an issue with,
everybody thinks oh my God,
if they found his tax returns,
they're gonna find all this.
I know every audit, I
know how it came out.
They're gonna find nothing.
You know what they will
find, is they'll find a lot
of money, which you just can
just prejudice somebody with.
Oh, look at all
the money he had.
But they're not gonna find.
- Right, having money isn't
illegal just yet, just yet.
- They're gonna probably
find a group of tax returns
that you can use in a tax course
about how to do it right,
because that's what he paid for.
- Yeah, well in many ways
it's usually that they're more
pissed about the rules,
rather than whether
someone broken them.
That, we can usually agree on,
let's clean up the tax code.
But that's a whole other thing.
So, I got one more thing for
you that'll sort of segue way
to the end here which is, I
mentioned at the beginning
you did the episode of
Seinfeld with the yogurt,
you did SNL where
you were in drag,
those things seem so
distant culturally,
from where we're
at now culturally.
Like, SNL would
never put you on now.
If there was a Seinfeld of now--
- Because I'm a
republican, right.
- Right, because you're a
republican and you know,
if there was a hot sitcom now,
there really isn't anything,
but if there was the
number one sitcom now,
it would never paint
you as a nice guy,
the way they painted you now.
I just thought maybe this could
sort of take us to the end,
which is as you've seen
the culture thing shift,
as a guy that was on
the other side of it
and now you're more
viewed as you know this,
by mainstream let's say, is
like the scary Trump republican
sort of thing,
how is that for you personally?
And then just also, as a
guy that's kept us calm
through some pretty
terrible times,
give me something hopeful,
give the audience something
hopeful over these next
couple of months, because I
sense people are really worried
that things are gonna
get back to anything
that looks like America from
literally four months ago.
- First of all, I am
very down about the idea
that we've been so
segmented and so stratified
that even my...
Warren Michaels is a
good friend of mine.
I sit right behind him
at the Yankee games.
I used to go on Saturday
Night Live all the time.
I haven't been invited now,
in 10 years.
I think I was pretty
good, I was pretty funny.
I've actually hosted
an entire show.
I have a secret
desire to be an actor,
always wanted to be an actor,
I guess that's why I
was a trial lawyer.
I was in Anger Management
and Out of Towners
and a lot of the
Law and Order stuff.
I played the beast and
Beauty and the Beast.
All kinds of roles, I
used to love doing that.
I'm glad I got the
chance to do it
because now you're right,
I would not have the chance
to do it.
Here's what I think is
hopeful, I think we're very,
very lucky and I
really mean this,
we're very, very lucky
to have a president
with an indomitable spirit.
Some other president,
given what he went through,
could be broken by it.
I mean, Nixon became an
alcoholic during the impeachment
thing, or at least it's
rumored that he did.
It could have
broken another man.
We're very lucky that he
has an indomitable spirit
because that'll
eventually prevail.
Once we get past the pandemic,
once this calms down and
it will, it always does,
it's gonna get
back to the economy
and how we're
functioning in jobs.
He's gonna do miracles with it.
I mean, he's got a remarkable
understanding of our economy.
Some of the things that
he's been able to do
really means that the
next recovery is gonna be
faster and stronger
than the last one.
Particularly, in boxing
out China so much.
I see it as there'll
be a rebirth.
The real question is,
if he gets reelected,
which I think he will,
and if he gets reelected
with a good spirit
of the economy at
least coming back,
will the democrats give
him at least two years
before we go into
the next election?
Somebody should get down
on their hands and knees
and beg them to do that for
the good of the country.
- Unfortunately, I think we
know the answer to that one.
- Well, maybe.
Maybe if they get defeated
maybe they're gonna have
to reform their party.
That's the only way
they're gonna get fixed.
The only way they're
gonna get fixed
is the way they got fixed
in the '80s or '90s,
when they finally
nominated Clinton
and he did the sister
soldier moment.
They had been going
to far to the left,
that we were trouncing them.
Clinton, although maybe he was
more left than he indicated
or certainly Hillary was,
Clinton made a pretty
good show in '92
that he was a
moderate candidate.
And he was after all, a governor
of a conservative state.
So he knew how to work
with conservatives.
It was in his DNA to work
with right wing senators
and assemblymen.
He always knew how to do that.
I mean, I had a great
relationship with Clinton.
I helped to pass the infamous
Prime Bill of 1994 with him
and I have a great
letter explaining
what a terrific mayor I am.
I was gonna use that if I
ever ran against Hillary.
(men laughing)
- Yeah, for sure.
Well listen, Mr. Mayor,
I'm thrilled that you
joined us for this.
You're one of the last heroes
that we have in America,
that actually stands up
for what they believe in.
You are.
That's the New Yorker in me.
- Well, thank you David.
- So, listen thank you so much.
- Great show.
- Stay safe in New
York, all right.
- I will, sir, you too.
- If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch
full interviews on
a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist, all right over here.
To get notified of
all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.